a group of top gop lawmakers is
demanding that nancy pelosi
answer for her security decisions
leading up to that
terrible day of january 6. now in a
letter to speaker pelosi the ranking
republicans on several key committees
right
five weeks have passed since the january
6 attack on the capitol building and
many important questions about your
responsibility for the security of the
capitol
remain unanswered end this political
charade and work with us to protect the
capital
my next guest is one of the lawmakers
behind that letter here now is devin
nunes
ranking member on the house intel
committee congressman
what decisions did she make in the lead
up to that
attack that concern you
we don't know because she won't answer
the question
of course the media is not asking the
tough questions and when they do kind of
hint around it
she dodges it but i know from that
morning
i spoke to several capitol police
officers on the morning of the six
that they were very concerned so at the
end of the day
she's the mayor of the capital she
should take responsibility
and if you notice this hasn't been
talked about either
laura if on saturday during the
impeachment circus impeachment number
two
remember there was that split time where
they thought all of a sudden that there
was going to be witnesses
well what happened is when donald
trump's team talked about
having witnesses they were going to call
her and then they took a break
and everything in a typical swamp
fashion in dc
disappeared there were no witnesses and
they voted to acquit donald trump
so she clearly doesn't want to answer
what happened
and what her roles and responsibilities
or her staff were on that day
how about the fact that major stories
that were reported were false
that a lot of media organizations still
haven't retracted fully
like you know police officers alleged to
have been killed by
you know fire extinguishers thrown by
trump supporters
and a horrible loss of life and a
horrible thing that happened
but that's not what happened but they
just repeat it because it helps their
narrative it's disgusting
it's disgusting all the way around i
think everyone's seeing through this at
this point
well i think everyone that watches fox
or
that is in the ghettos that are left to
conservatives on the internet
i think for the most part most americans
did not see
how badly the democrats from the house
were destroyed in the senate
about how they doctored evidence how
they falsified evidence and this was
presented to the u.s senate
this is not normal behavior in the
course of the history of the united
states of america but it's become the
norm over the last five years
as we've seen gone from russia hoax to a
fake impeachment to
this was really a debacle or i hope
everybody understands
i said it at the beginning of the show
watch watch that now it was a complete
disgrace from beginning to end and it
backfired on the democrats
they knew it and that's why they
backpedaled on the witnesses
congressman by the way fox5 is telling
us
and reporting that the national guard
could remain
in dc through the fall so we called
every governor's office in every single
state
to ask if they would allow their
guardsmen and women to participate
13 offices responded that their troops
have already been brought home
no state though said whether or not
they'd keep guardsmen in d.c through the
fall
if it's going to cost 500 million
through march
through the fall it's going to be well
over a billion dollars
for what reason exactly congressman
well look it's nice to see the military
out there they're great guys and i'm and
and women i mean thank god that they're
there
but the truth is they don't need to be
at the u.s capitol the fact of the
matter is
the guard could have been called in
fences should have been put up before
january 6 we had the intelligence uh in
order to do that
so so the fbi knew the fbi related that
to the capitol police
but now moving forward what i can tell
you is i haven't seen
any credible information whatsoever that
would lead that we would need
all the fencing and all the guardsmen
that are still there they need to go
home
madam secretary tear down that fence
congressman it's great to see you
tonight as always